if you don't have a big entourage in a
whole business organization how do I get
you for a film is it that I just send
you do I mail you a script is that it or
as a Darrell I do have an agent again
now but I did for four years not have
one I told everyone if you want me go to
James Howe Ely in London and he didn't
exist it was it was me on a different
email account is that right yeah you
made up a name yeah James Howe what is
it James Howe Ely James how healing I
used to fancy a goggle Dan how Healy she
wore big earrings and she was attractive
so James how really handled everything
he'd get these emails I said would say
can you get the script to Hugh and I
would write back yeah I'll try and get
him to read it this week I saved myself
an absolute fortune but the problem was
these people who are sending stuff they
wanted a personal relationship with
James they'd say we're coming to London
next week let's have lunch
did you ever call anyone as James Howe
Ely yeah I got rumbled in the end I
can't humble what happened but I James
had to get on the phone one time what
was James's voice like well I was
watching the Gulf and there was a
Scottish commentator so I thought right
he's Scottish
right and I did a pretty bad Scottish
accent like Michael I got a little mr.
Howe earlier how are you
what would you say oh that's right nice
to see you nice to hear from you how I
go that's cryptic you as fast as I can
now did you feel guilty doing that I did
a bit yeah and then and then I start to
slip up cuz if I'd had a drink or two
right I'd write emails as James Knight
sign off Hugh